thank you
uh
you guys see
and now i'm alive right we up but
i took them out okay and i'll just wait
and this is the admin class it is an
intensified key one
so
i'm just i'm stronger than him i thought
i'm higher than him okay
he can't get his arm in there try to get
your arm he's not gonna get it and i'm
not making this mistake
and i'm even looking for it can you tell
i'm looking for it now you see how it's
pinned
got it
so you don't want to if you feel that
i'm looking for it you see
then don't do it okay so you do the
other one
it's just gonna work back and forth
everyone feels space he's in okay
um
so he'll go he'll work what whatever
technique you want
boom
in okay
so i know he's gonna go to the box wait
so this is just
you're not deep enough
and get your head on my leg to protect
the
headlocks okay
i can tell he's working that way
but you don't want to stay still you're
going to do your
rui was a
guy's circling around you
so you're gonna circle around
him
okay he's gonna own that leg
okay
but here's where you fall
back we have the leg
okay
you know you you lost side control so
don't look for side control
look for what he wants he wants to go to
the back so i move so he doesn't trap
that okay
but he has to be
cognizant that i could do that so he
immediately he goes to trap the other
leg i can't do it
okay i now know
i'm not gonna brace here okay
and so as i feel him go
i'm going to put my back on the mat so
he doesn't get the back okay got it
all right
we'll put two and two together
as you guys saw
in this level of intensity he wants to
mount right away
and so he's gonna go for the mouth and
look what he did with his leg go back
look do it again slowly so we can see
you see go back
this leg was there
go
and i'm gonna use it okay
so go back
i said girls are getting it
as he brings his knee up
to go
put his knee on
go back
keep your connection he goes
and i trap him out here okay and then
you're a bridge away
[Music]
okay
and then we'll have you practice not
correctly so don't pull this knee in
right you're gonna go here
and you're gonna flip that knee into his
belly
and you flip over into the ankle and
knee hold
and then back into
the mouth position
okay
uh you're alive the whole time they give
you an opening you take the opening
stop stop you got to make sure when you
bridge that your feet are near your butt
each time don't spaz out
feet near your butt
tight
nope you got your your other hand goes
in on the way down
you have a you have a sequence to get to
you're going to give him an opening that
he's looking for you'll go back in side
control
okay
and make that mistake bring your knees
together as you're mounting
look for it
good
tight
try to work your way out good
okay
i can't get in
can't get in
if he can't get out
and he's not moving okay
so
i'm going to be ballistic
so my my movement is
you see that that was enough i got
enough room on both sides there okay
but
it's not it's ballistic nature that's
making it work
okay
so i'm not trying to build momentum and
that's what's working okay
so hold me down
hold me down
okay
you see push down
same way
um
[Music]
didn't use momentum it's
leverage structure
there's my space he's gonna come back
right
oh there i am
tight
again i'm going to do it ballistically
right so
ballistically
but its structure hold me down hold it
tight
you see
you're gonna hold me down
here april
oh
again it's done ballistically
holding down
you see
okay
around
got it already
okay
so again
try to try to move
move
he's only moving away
[Music]
move down your legs
go
that's side control
okay
get ready
but this is on my leg
here
you want sensitivity not
you neon belly
drive it in
okay so
your success isn't from you
moving faster than them
got it
okay